en las calles de nantech el sábado la
calma tras otra noche de violencia
coches quemados mobiliario urbano y
autobuses incendiados pero la noche fue
menos violenta que las anteriores en las
primeras horas de la mañana llega el
momento de limpiar en un ambiente
ligeramente surrealista en una ciudad
marcada por cuatro días de revueltas los
residentes dicen que entienden la ira
pero piden a apaciguamiento a una
persona el módulo
personalmente creo que deberíamos dejar
que el juez sea el juez no tiene sentido
reventar las cosas porque estamos
destruyendo nuestro barrio la gente que
rompe necesita panaderías farmacias
bancos de todo no estoy de acuerdo en
absoluto
un sentimiento que prevalece en el
barrio donde vivía El joven nael aunque
muchos dicen estar conmocionados por su
muerte
no tenemos más autobuses porque han
quemado las paradas y hay muchos coches
quemados Así que el autobús ya no
circula a pesar de que pasa por todos
los barrios de y luego por ejemplo hay
pequeños comercios que son destruidos
sin motivo alguno
una cólera que parecería dará paso a la
calma ya que el funeral del joven nael
se celebra este sábado